alors des choses qui ne sont pas
nécessairement agréable pour les petits
investisseurs qu'est ce qu'on fait dans
un contexte de grande volatilité comme
celui qu'on a connu cette semaine on
peut ce soir les questions à richard
morin il est président et chef de la
direction d'archers gestion de
patrimoine bonsoir monsieur morin
le même jour nous alors est ce que c'est
normal d'avoir un peu père peur de
perdre ses investissements dans une
période trouble comme celle qu'ont
convient tout en sachant que la peur
c'est loin d'être la meilleure
conseillère dans des circonstances comme
celles là
est ce que c'est normal oui on est comme
on et puis mon expérience monument qu'un
certain nombre d'investisseurs qui
disent mal avec la volatilité peut pas
porter de jugement là dessus il y en a
d'autres qui donnent comme des bébés
quand la bourse monte et descend je suis
parmi eux donc oui c'est normal est ce
qu'on doit faire quand ça arrive c'est
absolument rien c'est pas le moment de
bouger de faire quoi que ce soit parce
que moi je suggérer aux investisseurs de
départ du canard un beau week end de
printemps québec pour faire beau doit
faire chaud ou chose bon ça dit elle
quand même des gens qui nous écrivent
des gens qui vous appelle certainement
est-ce que ce sont ceux qui sont près de
la retraite qui sont plus inquiets ou
est-ce que ça n'a rien à voir avec l'âge
généralement c'est rien à voir avec
l'âge avant je pense qu'on devrait
mettre les choses en perspective on a
connu une baisse des marchés boursiers
américains et un peu plus que 10 % au
canada ça vaut mieux des baisses de 10 %
dans les marchés ça arrive à peu près
tous les 18 mois on les baisse de 20%
dans les marchés boursiers à peu près
tous les quatre ans donc ce qui se passe
n'est pas
inhabituel anormal la chose qui est
particulière c'est qu'en ce moment les
actions descendent en même temps que les
obligations
ça fait déjà un bon train tant qu'on
n'avait pas connu ça pour en revenir à
votre question
je pourrais choisir trois investisseurs
qui voient comment tests que ça vous ne
réglez les infectés ou ne pas les
objectifs qui se passe en ce moment
c'est ça dont la 40 45 ans on a encore
du temps devant nous avant la retraite
quels conseils avez vous pour ces gens
là
là une personne de 45 ans fait
placement de 50 ans elles vont
probablement vivre jusqu'à 90 95 ans
donc le portefeuille qu'elle a
aujourd'hui cette personne va conserver
pendant une cinquantaine d'années ce qui
arrive aujourd'hui la semaine prochaine
le mois prochain où l'an prochain était
presque sans importance pour cette
personne en fait quand ça descend c'est
l'opportunité d'acheter des titres moins
cher dans le marché ils sont 10% moins
cher aujourd'hui qu'il l'était yoland
allons acheter donc pour cet
investisseur on regarde la discipline
ont continué d'investir régulièrement
et pour ceux qui sont par exemple plus
près de la retraite ou à la retraite
quels conseils avez vous
si on commence à un trait tout son
étalon de retraite on devait avoir un
bon plan financier le plan financier
doive basées sur des hypothèses de
landes marianiste l'hypothèse qu'on
utilise a préféré pour un portefeuille
équilibré ses 4 % par année si vous
regarde malgré la base qu'on vient de
connaître ce portefeuille équilibré au
cours des trois mêmes au cours des cinq
dernières années a fait 5 % par année à
te ferais rien de tout ça ne sort des
normes on est à l'intérieur des
hypothèses donc même pour deux retraités
il ya un lien de particuliers à faire en
ce moment malgré l'adresse peut-être
temporaire des marchés cette fois ce qui
nous pend au bout du nez on suppose
qu'il va se passer l'an prochain mais
rien qui justifie quand j'en ai loupé
d'un financier bon sang quand même que
depuis deux mois on dort plus on
s'inquiète est ce que certains de revoir
le portefeuille de réévaluer la
tolérance au risque
je dirais non c'est pas en pleine
tempête qu'on doit tenter de passer d'un
avis à un autre
navire est probablement le bon aussi
n'ai pas le don c'est pas le moment en
ce moment de 1 - vraiment que vous soyez
capable que vos finances ne vous permet
pas de perdre deux prochains et 5 ou 10%
là vous êtes dans une situation
différente
mais pour l'investisseur moyen qui se
posent des questions
allez voir votre conseiller financier il
vous connaît il connaît votre situation
financière colin probablement votre
tolérance de votre capacité à assumer
louise allé le voir il est compétent
faites lui confiance il va bien vous
conseiller mais que diriez vous
or s'ils sont peut-être pas les
meilleurs véhicules d'investissement
pour les gens qui sont pressés et
anxieux ou encore on se prive d'un
rendement pour tous devrait pas se
passer il faut un peu enterrés cet ce
stress là
la bourse d'abord parce qu'on n'a plus
de fonds de pension à prestations
déterminées on doit tous investir en
bourse c'est impossible d'atteindre nos
objectifs financiers puis nos objectifs
de retraite à long terme à moins
d'investir en bourse puis dans le marché
obligataire donc on est tous ont pu le
condamner à le faire mais c'est pas pour
l'investisseur moyen est une infime
minorité d'investisseurs qui est capable
de gérer c'est d'abord de faire son
propre plan financier bien sûr d'avoir
les connaissances puis la discipline de
gérer son portefeuille
c'est presque impossible pour un
investisseur de faire encore une fois et
des conseillers financiers qui sont là
ils sont compétents
il c'est leur boulot de faire ces deux
choses pour vous 2 par le conseil le
plan financier et d'autre part gérer
votre portefeuille de façon compétente
alors on écoute vos conseils me suis
mariée on va jouer dehors y annonce beau
en fin de semaine et on ne consulte pas
notre rôle de placement je remercie
beaucoup d'avoir été là merci pour vos
conseils merci c'est un plaisir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez vous
sur la chaîne ici et redit